thomas ist von der montage zurück und
entsetzt rachael vernachlässigt für
schweinchen egon die familie wächst du
noch sauber herzlich kommt zu einem
neuen video leute freut mich dass sie
eingeschaltet hat denn alleiniger
einschalten habt ihr bereits bewiesen
dass ihr zu den stabilsten säugetieren
gehört jemals diese erde bevölkert haben
also schon mal kompliment an euch ich
habe letztens ein bisschen das internet
durchforsten ob das mit dem
hintergedanken gemacht den ja auch bald
sehen werdet dass ich ein bisschen
abwechslung mal ein kanal reinbringen
werde heute ist freitag würde dieses
video seht am sonntag wird ein ganz
anderes video kommen also sonst am kanal
kommt und ja bei diesem stück habe nicht
ein bisschen umgeschaut hat mir das
angeschaut welche videos könnten
eventuell entschwindet seien für action
und ja also heute haben wir wirklich ein
video am start das da übertrifft allein
der titel nur der titel des videos schon
jegliche erwartung dich überhaupt ans
leben hatte es elf leute wenn ihr werde
ich euch 1000 versuche gegeben hätte den
titel dieses videos zu erraten wir
werden nicht drauf gekommen weil so
geisteskrank sind selbst hier nicht ich
würde immer wieder leute wie schauen
heute weil in das video schweinerei
meine freundin hat mich durch ein
minischwein ersetzt bei dem titel habe
ich schon gar kein bock mehr
[Musik]
da haben wir anscheinend schon den
übeltäter leute also leute wirklich so
gesagt lass uns darüber nachdenken
welche videos wie bereits gesehen haben
von hilfen es ist eine menge
wir haben die menge an videos gesehen
habe auf eine menge ja schon reagiert
wir haben auch ein mann reagiert der
sich als kleines mädchen verkleidet wir
haben auf menschen reagiert die die
partner ihrer geschwister oder eltern
sich schnecken natürlich auch auf das
eine oder andere pärchen reagiert wo der
junge das mädchen mästet aber also retov
wenn ich mich anstrengen würde ich
könnte nicht auf so eine scheiße kommen
12 das ist unser neues haustier das ist
max sechs jahre alte habe ich auf der
straße irgendwo gefunden
es ist habt ihr ein menschliches kind
als haustier das ist das ist egon ihr ja
jetzt nicht ernst ja alles kann es wird
aber die ganze zur das clip gezeigt ja
ja ich hatte ja noch diese alte uhr von
obama wissen was wäre da bin ich
rausgegangen sind in den untergrund
gegangen und habe mich da in der
kanalisation einfach mal wenn vieles
gekauft
kannst du ging er wegen einer
tierhaarallergie nicht außerdem haben
okay okay leute ein wahrer sie haben
sich doch kein kind gekauft es handelt
sich tatsächlich im hausschwein nächste
frage also mal ganz davon abgesehen was
angeblich in dieser folge doch mit
diesem schein passieren soll
ja also darüber müssen überhaupt geredet
der stelle lasst uns mal reparieren
warum man sich nicht nach hause wieso
also noch leute mit sich aber auch
einige von euch im haus sprechen zu
hause
ich leide jetzt sogar das wort aber für
mich so ein bisschen verwirrend klingt
aber also ich kann für mich selbst sagen
kein schwein ins haus holen die auch ja
sie streichelt den jungen also sorry
aber worüber reden wir jetzt habt ihr
euch einen menschen gekauft oder ein
schwein gehabt jetzt beides gezeigt die
frau steigend den jungen er ist so süß
jung war auch von günstig und ständig
weiter in den jungen mann jetzt auch
beides gekauft das schwein und jungen
zusammen beweist ich meine wie andere
überlegt dass erstmals ein zu lassen mal
seit drei monaten habe ich jetzt wieder
den job wir sind froh dass über die
runden kommen übrigens leute falls ihr
euch gefragt habt dessen leben es ist an
der stelle die antwort liegt relativ
klar auf der hand ist es ihr leben ja
nur damit er mal keine verwirrung
aufkommt ist das machte ich dachte was
das viehfutter aufwand macht wo schläft
das was gibt's zu fressen
diesen dreckig ohne ende oder will
sollte diese ganzen sachen wird 1000
wagen dadurch dass man einfach dass sie
einfach so doppeldeutig sprechen das
könnte beides jetzt entweder das
gekaufte kind oder auch das gekaufte
schreibens bezogen seit alternative
kinder erst mal sind die unfassbar teuer
in der anschaffung dann machen schweine
sind die hygienischen tiere die es
überhaupt gibt auch von der stelle muss
ich diese top ton ist hier niemand
beleidigt der sich eventuell ist also
andere hausschwein oder das eine oder
andere haus kamel zu hause hält aber
dann waren schweinderl ich diese tiere
die so gefühlt alles fressen und sich im
eigenen dreck suhl 3 millionen des lecks
von hausschweinen inhaber und ständig
hier alleine
jetzt jetzt kommen wir so langsam bei
einem kern des ganzen ist mir dann
gerade erst an
übrigens heute ganz kurzer zwischenruf
ich hab meine airports wahrscheinlich
schon wieder verloren weil ich der
allerletzte dummkopf bin ich doch meine
ja fast schon verloren aber okay dort
aber so langsam kommen bei dem saftigen
teil an leute jetzt jetzt entwickelt
sich das drama was der kern dieser folge
ist nämlich dass sie sich von ihrem
freund vernachlässigt fühlt und die
lösung dafür ist dass ihnen mit einem
schwein besitzt das hätte rachel
natürlich mit ihrem mann absprechen
müssen und dass er nicht gerade
begeistert ist das hat sie
wahrscheinlich auch erwartet und ich
kann verstehen dass sie als hausfrau und
mutter vielleicht nach einer abwechslung
sucht ja also suche nach abwechslung in
allen ehren und wahrscheinlich es ist
auch nicht ganz so geil wenn man halt so
wollte klitschko die hausarbeit macht
und klar der mann sind wir draußen
unterwegs wo sich die nicht so oft aber
warum ist die antwort darauf sich
schwein an zu schaffen machen wie das
heutzutage so dass man wenn man
irgendwelche mentalen probleme hatte ein
problem das man sich einfach ein tier
anschafft sogar den letzten wochen
schlecht drauf
irgendwann bist du dir sicher dass das
funktioniert nicht bemerken ich
verspreche
sicher kann sich verantworten das
schwein in seiner wohnung bemerkt leute
hier wird ja alle wissen dass schweine
undercover sind ja nicht umsonst hätte
ich meine so erfolgreiche jäger ja gut
versorgt ein großartig zu sagen nein
wie wäre es mit nein oder wie wäre es
mit
du kranke sei warum ersetzte mich mit
mini schwein super dann haben wir ja
wirklich jetzt feiert seit wochen
versuche ich schon der rachael das
auszureden und ich hab extra schon so
eine tierhaarallergie erfunden aber nein
jetzt haben wir so ein ding hier und ich
meine das kostet zwar für diesen fall
ekelhaft doch unabhängig davon ob das
ding jetzt viel kostet oder ob du eine
ausgedachte tierhaarallergie hast du dir
gar nicht mehr sagen zumal vorhält ich
habe davor sich ich bin mit seiner frau
verheiratet seine frau angeblich
heiraten kommen so nach hause und schaue
was geht da gibt man kurze schnauze noch
einmal kommen die so jung
ich habe schwein gekauft sonst alles gut
wird
ein paar tage später matches man ist
wieder auf montage
die 26 jährige lenkt sich mit
hausschwein egon ab bei aller liebe ist
26 jährige lenkt sich mit aus schweiz
muss los bruder ganz sicher bestimmt
ganz gut hausschwein ihr solltet ihr
mini hausschwein welches durch gelernt
wurde mit krücken welche mit
hautpflegeprodukten eingeben werden
würde also sagen der verdacht erhärtet
sich dass diese frau hier tendenziell
eher nicht mehr zu retten ist
ja also ich muss an der stelle auch
zugeben meine kernkompetenz ist es nicht
für in hilf mir folgende auftretende
minischweine zu sprechen aber ich weiß
nicht ob der oberste wunsch von einem
schwein ist gewaschen zu werden wie man
ist ein schwein so bist du wieder
gedankengang leute aber wenn ich mir
vorstellen dass ich ein schwein werden
kann ich will einfach nur in meinem
dritten versuch mich da ganz andere
scheiße wo wir sind menschen wir müssen
zwar gibt sich den ganzen unsinn ich
soll meine menschen diskutieren darüber
wird ist für mich das richtig ist mir
egal mein oberstes ziel in diesem moment
ist es einfach den schlauch vom
duschkopf zu essen so ticken schwannecke
muss man noch mehr zu diesen tieren
sagen seine seine halter diskutieren
literally darüber welches duschgel oder
shampoo für ihn das richtige ist und
währenddessen ist er einen schlauch okay
er ist einfach den schlauch thomas ist
von der montage zurück und entzerrt
rachael vernachlässigt für schweinchen
egon die familie text das sauber-team
vernachlässigt für schweinchen egal die
familie kleine rote ein sehr weit
verbreitetes problem in deutschland
immer mehr hausfrauen vernachlässigen
ihrer familie für kleine leute wenn ihr
auch schon mal von eurer mutter wegen
eines hausschweins vernachlässigt wurde
dann like dieses video kommentiert und
abonniert meinen kanal war das noch
nicht passiert das dann macht das ganze
aber trotzdem wollen natürlich ganz
wichtig für euch rund um kirche einfach
ich vorgeschlagen könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren das war so was von mir wie
gesagt ich versprochen in zwei tagen am
sonntag mal wieder richtige abwechslung
auf diesen kann also völlig darauf bis
dahin macht's gut getragen